cream cocoa from comic-con what's going
on Blaine here here with Beth murasky in
the chat we'll Becton in the creeper in
the corner and today we were very
excited I don't know if you can tell
from my pewpewpewpew shirt but today
we're playing a little bit of Star Wars
Battlefront on ps4 with you guys so add
me Blair's and we were gonna get you
into a match - especially guys stopping
by today very exciting Beth
yesterday we had a couple of the San
Diego Padres Robbie
urlan and Eric Johnson a couple of
pitchers one righty one Lefty both on
the DL list and they're rehabbing and we
were part of their rehab schedule
yesterday yes which is very exciting we
also had mr. jordan shlonsky stopped by
yesterday which was fun is a strong word
but I will say interesting we learned a
lot that's true such as the Japanese
soundtrack soundtrack of the first
Richard Donner Superman film left off
two of the songs the other John way of
score why does he know that we're fine
so epic the fourth good to see you
Sacramento Dulce how are you Billy
ringer that's a nice thing to say
Wow YouTube starting off strong so once
again if you guys a clawzord 2 to 7 you
just have to watch the stream to find
out where the special guest is and as
always I'm drinking how do you say this
look look Lucroy we love you Lacroix so
yeah so we're very excited our first
show is tonight it's gonna be amazing
super fun I'm gonna play
I'm gonna go 12 players shoot shoot pew
pew pew pew here we go
find the best hero game it's gonna be
fun
will we do the Batman telltale Game Nerd
cubed fan 1 3 2 I didn't know there was
a Batman telltale game
that's very exactly yeah I mean we will
those telltale games are great oh we're
gonna get creamed there's four on six
this can't be good we can take it
which might turn up the TV a little bit
or here throw me tear up thanks man
thank you sir
Jorge Luis or is it George Luiz
where is Conan Conan currently is
working out he works out in the mornings
I had to get his blood up for these
Comic Con shows there's also a fly in
here which is the worst our office is
full of 200 we've chosen a pizza oven
for our office here
Garth butters I like Jordan to come in
and offer and express a recommendation
based on similarity to the Star Wars
universe you can do it I know it he
could but he's not going to today he was
here yesterday he might be coming in
later in the week yeah he might be
coming a lair thermal detonator it is
empty slot I'm going oh you know what I
like to have a thermal detonator
actually for my for this one and this
one let's have that's great there we go
let's do it and once again I'm gonna
play one game without you guys to give
you guys time get this game going yeah
and then we're gonna play it I think
you're gonna want to play this game it's
very fun here we go we're playing heroes
heroes is great oh my god 360 degrees
well played we are doing a lot of 360
stuff here
[Music]
can we talk about what Conan's doing
tonight or not good next here we missed
you too oh my god
oh Jesus Skywalker you know what's great
about this game I've said it before I'll
say it again in the movies since you
follow all the heroes you know you
follow these guys around so you don't
really get the sense cuz they're all
fighting each other you don't really get
the sense of how powerful they are
compared to the normal people but in
this game you really get the sense of
like how would you ever beat Darth Vader
in combat you wouldn't he just goes
around just killing everybody and so
that's kind of a cool thing that I
didn't really realize before this game
came out how badass these guys truly are
that's one thing I'm kind of excited
about for rogue one the new Star Wars
story is you'll kind of it'll follow
real people in in the Star Wars universe
and it won't just be all these
superpower that's the thing with the
Avengers it's like when Ironman is
fighting Hulk great battle by the way my
favorite of the whole Avengers franchise
when that's happening it's just two
super-powered guys fighting each other
which is really cool but like you know
they're just the Hulk is like insane
like how would you ever fight him like
it's crazy
I do like in the comics I don't know if
you guys have read any of the new
Ultimates well now they're not super new
but uh where the Hulk just takes down an
entire alien armada it just gives you
some totally nuts they can't stop him
can't play kiss but what about you
that's a good third-person view how do i
do third-person view
oh there's Skywalker
sorry games are done I didn't know games
were done they are yes
we're playing vintage I love there's
like 50 50 guys running after Skywalker
are we just all supposed to kill the
hero is that the ideas I think it is
right I gotta say some get some boards
people don't work together this board I
feel like we're all working together oh
Jesus
oh God dead hold the down arrow for
third person view thank you
third person view coming up boom third
person view it is oh my god Oh who's the
who's the next hero I just heard like
crazy laughing
solo so is a bastard crimes against the
Empire this way look at this big
backpack why have I got this huge
backpack on man it's oh it's full of
snacks so what kind of Star Wars snacks
are there yeah that's the meat where's
solo oh I love that guy's voice we've
tracked an Skywalker
kill the smug gonna bring me his head to
serving snack packs days dude can't even
see the game comrade Bungie what do you
mean you can see the game perfectly I
love you too Jace bar milk Oh blue milk
of course
aunt Beru I'm flowin Justin Bieber
where's Kirk Kirk is not in this game
but good joke
I'm tired of man people not knowing Star
Trek and Star Wars you know yeah oh
we've been playing a lot of Pokemon down
here it's real fun Pokemon this town is
filthy with Pokemon absolutely filthy
it's great you're streaming thank you
for thank you Joe Joe shell um thank you
for watching this pineapple belong of
the pizza Zoma is don't make a chicken
ah yes absolutely but only with ham oh
my god damn good Skywalker where's our
headquarters in San Diego we are at the
Spreckels theater over here come see us
we are giving away people who get in the
audience pop dolls and there are four
it's a mystery which one is going to be
tonight
what are the four we've announced them
right joke Conan is the Joker
stormtrooper I love this
and and there's good there are specials
this is just for people like continued a
go but there's nap chat closers respond
so there we go yeah we killed Skywalker
oh my god yes so on Saturday and on
Sunday night that's right Friday we have
a TV TV airing yes
so no show Friday there are other
excellent TBS programming on a Friday
that's right
he league I think right yep Ewing give
me some good power-ups
please say one piece of criticism what
piece is criticism about what this game
I'll tell you a piece of criticism about
this game that there's no split-screen
online multiplayer option that oh wow I
got murdered there should be you should
be able to bet then I should be able to
play online with people that's it
yum yum yum yum that's it
no no we have to kill Mew
that's my favorite guy who's Skywalker
sucks no he doesn't he's awesome
you guys the best thank you our breads
you're the best and also I love bread
Daniel Mark Martina is our Martin Martin
Martin Martinez Wow
I got killed by that guy killed me so
yeah I don't care about there already is
split screen offline favorite Star Wars
character
ooh I mean I like your Han Solo's who
else do I like
I like ig-88 pretty cool neum nib Mon
Mothma I'm excited about the young Mon
Mothma is gonna be in rogue one spoilers
know what who are we hunting down now
it's still NIM young this is ps4 whoever
asked that question synth or Jedi ooh
you got a go Jedi man because the sit
there is only two of them right there's
the omastar in the apprentice so that'd
be lonely like you wouldn't have what if
you're Sith master or apprentice is it
this dick yeah that's like yeah I know
one to talk to about like like how do I
work these powers you know oh man I had
Wow four deaths zero kills well that's
embarrassing
yes I would like to alright let's see if
there's some people playing so we can
get a match going no first person view
Steven I was asked to put it on third
person yeah
that's right no place to be you Jedi I
mean I guess I'm more see no one is
playing it let's go to our let's go to
our friends here how do I do that let's
put our friends all friends friend
requests accept all these ding ding ding
ding ding that's right and with robotic
Willy sent to 1614 accept my request
robotic Willy you jerk
it's been too long what's your problem I
don't see anybody playing this
how did see anybody playing all right
we're gonna play again then find the
last 40 player game let's do it
let's get epic it's gettin epic I want
to put one of these new maps y'all gonna
play y'all gonna play dark butters y'all
gonna play freakin robots in Willie's
hey Carlos Gonzales what's up
who's on show tonight starting off big
with the old silicon you got your middle
ditches yeah you got a you got your you
got your your your Zachary Zachary woods
your Z woods we did a awesome Halo
multiplayer FPS gamer with the old
Silicon Valley folks they were the best
we're gonna play a basket nap one of the
new ones this is fun starting it up says
alive vixx
a megabyte got a lot of fun friends oh
this is gonna be great
ooh and I'm a rebel baby you know it the
role I was born to play slash I'm scared
to play cuz I am afraid of authority so
I don't know if I would ever I probably
would just be an imperial dude just cuz
I'd be scared I was gonna get like a
ticket like a like a ticket or something
you know oh my god Walker salt Cloud
City oh this is awesome
Walker smells great I will say one thing
that battlefront does very well the
whole series they do a really good job
with making this scale really cool yeah
so like you can be in a walker you could
be in a TIE fighter like it's awesome
like you can be in these giant ships and
like everything you see you can play it
which is really cool
that's one of my favorite things where
are the space battles they're coming hey
what's up Frank H rebel scum Sanada Hal
of ik how dare you hi from Canada hey
King dismiss exactly future old by me
old man and lowly what
Oh J Michael Sui asked what would I
dress up as icons played this year
that's a good question
I would probably dress up as um I like
going old school so I might ghost like
Snake Plissken
you know from escape from New York you
ever seen that John Carpenter's Snake
Plissken although the whole thing is I
thought oh I thought you were dead and
but then I thought you'd be taller and
I'm pretty tall uh I also like who else
what I like to be maybe like what about
like a mashup like a big cup with like
bubbles in it and then a Boba Fett mask
I could be boba tea Fett thank you put
it up put it up put it up for that put
it up for that I'm forcing a high five
upon you here we go let's do it let's
stop these walkers oh my god how are we
ever gonna stop these walkers Jesus God
Oh vehicle turret here we go dude this
is awesome look at this holy jesus I
killed him though did I kill him I got
one guy I can watch it work yeah Shady
boba tea Fett open star society loves it
we go let's go baby
we've got to get out of this kill zone
this is crazy by the way this is insane
doesn't work everybody should how do we
stop these walkers guys
here come the x-wings Jesus somebody
save us this is awesome
I'll attack the Walker let's get on
there dude I love this game yeah I think
we killed it see you guys oh I got
killed why more it's such a dumb hat I'm
going all-in
dinah man 2 no Gus Yeah right raven dark
we are streaming every day from
comic-con until saturday 11 to noon wow
there's a lot of destruction happening
I'm sure my little handgun is doing
wonders on this thing oh jeez 8:08 EST
got me too
oh I have on me it's my hand I'm
changing blasters up blaster rifle hey I
can't do this it's happening okay let's
go
I find your lack of kills mr. yeah well
you're gonna find a lot of the stuff
stirring because I'm terrible oh Jesus
Oh what was that missile incoming
do we have any interesting stories about
being a comic-con I have a lot of
interesting stories
went to the Playboy party last year
Wow got sniped from up above Boba Fett
Boba Fett I didn't know you could be a
UH I know the heroes were in this what's
an introduced story from last year well
I mean it's it's great like it's always
God you always get into crazy situations
at comic-con because there's so much Wow
well that sucked
our today's gonna be the guest today
perfect we're there you go Lula fawn
went to the playboy party uh what's a
little party last year and as you know
Pam are one of our friends Pam and
Amelia who are the game from gamer next
door from comic-con oh that's really bad
[Music]
she was supposed to be there and I
didn't see her and I didn't see her and
I was like oh man won't know where she's
at with all of a sudden everyone cheers
and they brought this giant plane like
people were carrying this huge plane and
this person is on it with two like roman
candles going like this in a bunny suit
I looked up and I was like I said she
was that party all right
pretty great
came from the office and from the office
it was Pam from the office how do you
sir what happened in jail what's Jenna
Fischer doing these days
wait we got to get back up
all right ones locked in I need that
other uplink you oh wow oh the walkers
firing to me
oh I'm not going out there I just saw
three people get murdered by that's a
grenade for baby offline what which ones
offline this one
that's a that's an explosive explosive
thingy Bumi's oh dude Danny ran right
past my thing what a grenade goodnight
thanks for the fun stuck interstate this
is awesome Tori I'm you're awesome Thank
You private
thank you for watching if you're just
joining us we are streaming live from
the Spreckels theater every day till
Saturday start at 11:00 till noon
special guests every day you got a I
wonder who's gonna be today's special
guests nobody knows nobody knows
Partners start this guy is from the Old
Republic or something I'm in a shield
hahaha I got him in the back though
whoo I think I think we're are we gonna
get killed here I think they just got
the Atta
oh wow I got killed feel me to come in
Tyler Silva if you want me to come in as
a special yeah we did it
nice rebel scum rebel scum one imperial
imperial dicks zero why was I not one of
the top three you see my amazing stats I
got hey guys I did so up game alright
who else is playing this let's get let's
get a game going new pals pals new pals
later also we might play a little rocket
League if you've got that on ps4 we're
gonna switch us in rocket league in a
little bit very exciting go rebels there
we go Elijah you know what I'm talking
about
it's yeah they're even with DLC I don't
know what that means
whoa oMG it's Rex hit level 70 my
gamertag's my last name Blair so uh
friend me I'm all see thank you for
joining us I don't know
it was default and tennis yeah and you
know it's pretty I think ladybugs are
friends of the garden right I think no I
think they eat the like I learned bar
think are ladybugs cuz you're gonna like
farm ladybugs like mantis see like
praying mantises you know you can farm
ladybugs I think they help you out guys
do you are ladybugs good or bad
somebody's like nobody is in this here
you would know how do I see this isn't
this isn't working for me is anybody is
anybody in in this game or should we
just play rocket League maybe you play
one more of these play one more of these
and then
[Music]
I think maybe we switch to rocket League
I don't see because we played all right
we're gonna play rocket me we're doing
it we out nobody's nobody's playing Star
Wars Battlefront sorry oh no rocket
League please alright people are saying
rocket League so rocket League it is
ladybugs muy bueno there you go
muy muy well I love it so much play
division alright great
alright shady well thank you thank you
for joining us shady that was nice of
you
we out laters oh yeah play online creep
private match let's do it
we're doing it guys the match name is
tunes are the best match name is Coco
the password is also Coco remember last
time that people took over our room so
we couldn't play exactly and we're
playing in Neo Tokyo because why not
ya already ladybugs destroyed crops
that's what I thought what I thought
they were good though don't be bugs I
just have an image of them eating like
green plants don't think bugs I think
y'all is crazy
hmmm alright people throw down those
game coco coco i thought i'd find your
lack of battlefront disturbing well
played I'm enjoying blue oh wait oh wait
this didn't work we got to get people
time I think to play match flame beacon
next close gamer coming soon hopefully
frame raid yes my bank paint is cocoa
and I would definitely say it on a
stream like this
all right here we are who's getting in
rocket League how do I join the in
Slough of Rivia look for the coke search
for match Coco Coco Coco you should be
able to join it's not soccer its
football I'm not gonna get into this
situation
yeah nobody wins here we go
oh [ __ ] master is in how ironic is it
just gonna be me versus if master people
are spectating get in there guys I think
you people join as it goes on
oh here we go come on all right I'm
joining I'm up I'm blue sympathiser
scored let's go
whoo I need to see replay how do you see
replay uh nannies see replay
oh this one's got a weird Oh jump in the
middle
let's go baby I like mio Tokyo a lot by
the way
it's a cool
oh I missed it yeah next job said faster
join us you place this kuba Dave Thank
You Cuba
what up Cobra I enjoy the twitch y'all
do hey thanks Nick Revell yes mr. Conan
hit anyone more than Aaron no donuts no
one more than me he used to had a guy
named Michael Coleman
more than me and one time even I think
something happened they were in his
office and I had to go and he I was
called into Komen's office to put his
hand on his head to hold his head down
while counting got a sandwich and then
of course I let him go should see a
little roughhouse and boys will be boys
guys am i right boys will be boys the
enter key was awesome oh they have two
trophies left in DLC and over on the
game itself Wow flame beacon we did you
yeah we looked Diana to she's the best
ran into Diana last down the street
here's a fun comic continent story and
everyone was apparently is San Diego big
on ice cream sandwiches does anybody
know we're talking a lot of ice cream
sandwich yeah oh yeah you were with
those guys last night how did this come
about this ice cream sandwich business
we heard someone started rumors at San
Diego the big ice cream sandwich town
yeah who is that who started the rumor
was this what one of our own and then he
went to his DBS and I think he bought
like a tool of those that's how the
night ended up
there's McDonald's and français yeah
exactly
Royale with cheese etc etc Danica's
watching the stream you just like me
it's all Dickson's fault
Danny get back to work we were doing
watching this stream danik sitting like
10 feet though 20 feet yeah put a link
up played against OCONUS comic-con game
John Danny did it fueled by ice cream
sandwiches that's right only only ice
cream just what somebody asked in the
chat what would kind of do for a
Klondike bar
right now nothing because I think he's I
think he's he's in a pretty healthy
workout regimen where he's uh off dairy
he's off gluten I'm not sure what else I
think he's got to get that Comic Con
shape you know he had to be in superhero
shape for this week
um I've decided I'm gonna play oh here
we go
cross cross it
oh this might be my favorite board I
love this board there's a lot of
power-ups too which is great
Oh get in there there's no ringers in
this game either except for maybe SIF
master it seems we do it pretty well d
me Oh Conrad Bungie well done
we got a birthday in the house Tori
whose birthday is it you want carne
asada fries or Durham girl it's the girl
single I like when people say he's the
girl I'm not sure what yeah girl head
girl has she's an assassin that's for
sure I am I do kill whoo let's save that
shot that better be my stats how do you
blow people up oh yeah boom that's
number two I saved two one this is a
close game damn it I hate going oh we
gotta block that [ __ ] out son
someone said I would like to say these
dreams are fun to watch and I really
enjoy them thank you and you can see all
the past broadcast we've done to
archived on our channels twitch that TV
/ - Koko and youtube.com slash Team Coco
let's oh damn it how did somebody do
that flip around spiral thing GTFO come
on yes we got it nailed
well done blue my boy blue hold on y'all
I'm not sure why I'm not doing any cool
tricks what can I do them oh I see I
could just do it myself
yeah flip around spiral thing ooh
King just dismiss this are we gonna go
back to panel fire should I turn off the
ps4 should we go back to battle French
at your I feel like our special guest is
gonna be better at Rocket Lee friend
Battlefront might be a little intense
but you know what we'll ask our special
guest it'll be up to our special guest
how about that well let that will let
our special guest figure it out rematch
what are you most excited about for this
comic-con I'm most excited sleeping two
hours yeah I'm very excited about what
our switch teams this time join an
orange
well mostly so I think I'm value today
is not only fun I can't wait I'm pumped
to see Suicide Squad the Suicide Squad
folks big fan of the those guys you know
Will Smith it doesn't get any bigger
than yeah amazing Game of Thrones folks
last year we did a great Conan did a
great opera prom photo with Game of
Thrones people watch is real fun
those people are so nice oh my god
everyone on that cast is just the nicest
coolest coolest people ever yeah and
everyone yeah and so is Hunger Games
folks are cool everyone is cool man it's
Comic Con I think it's hard to be in a
bad mood
cuz it's just really fun the vibe at
Comic Con is like oh I almost hit the
ball the vibe at Comic Con is it's a
celebration you know it's just very fun
of all things nerdy and great which
makes me happy because I was a kid that
wasn't really the kids it was Jay was
just jock Khan I lived in Chaka Khan
Chaka Khan next screaming X game with
gravity's there gravity or gravitas
David
man
there we go there we go there we go ah
I've got for some food is where his
battle friends this shade necks I guess
I mean I guess you guys want to see
Battlefront I thought this would be more
fun but maybe we go back to Battlefront
no one was playing battlefront we wanted
to play with you guys you know what how
about this we'll go to battle back to
battlefront after this game I feel like
that way we played with some fans right
yeah and that way I feel like the
special guest and I could just trade off
lives right
[Music]
but knowing our special guests I feel
like the special guys might be better at
this game
yeah did you think our special guests
would just maybe get a little annoyed
forced to play battlefront exactly
shout out to Ashley I ever since her
birthday all right Gabriel shut up -
Ashley Ivor's happy bday oh it's raining
you know what's the you would think like
there seems to be a lot of electronic
equipment in this stadium I'm not sure
this is great for the rain you want to
put a roof on this thing right he
protects my last name king dymas thank
you flame begin for helping out astro
fan 82 but he puts on battlefront that's
all the man rocket leaves yeah I know
the way you guys worried it's the first
person third person thing you guys just
like to screw with me that's right I did
give you guys a chance by the way to
play battlefront I gave you guys a half
hour to get battlefront yeah that's
right you guys had plenty of time to
play battlefront so I don't want to hear
any whining nice job silence or George
Lucas special guest confirmed
yeah I don't think he plays game and
video games
I did have Lucas arts he only plays
battlefront under like Jango Fett 78
yeah what if he's like level 70 I'm
Battlefront nobody knows it was funny we
had Freddie Prinze jr. in a little while
back and he was talking about how him
Dave Chappelle shannen doherty
some other people all were really
hardcore or the workout fans and would
play all the time because they can be
anonymous nobody knows although you
would get I mean you would know if
Chappelle was like talking to you like
hey babe you know like that's my patient
impression a human baby but yeah you I
think that's it's interesting because
video games allow celebrities need to be
anomaly anonymous oh well well it's our
special guest Andy Richter everybody
completes in the middle
all right that's right everyone do you
want to play oh [ __ ] no oh [ __ ] oh let's
say hi to the chat Andy hi chat that's
right everyone if you got questions for
the great Andy Richter now it's your
time no no no I'm not taking nothing
what's a quiz show that of course no
it's one of those he's gonna put some
AMAs yeah I know internet stuff Andy are
you excited about being back at
comic-con the shoes I mean I I can sweat
virtually anywhere why not beautiful San
Diego right exact time well I'm well
there are people that are as old as me
that are into this stuff but I still
feel like I'm too old for this I know I
did a little well but you know at least
like it was more a part of your youth
sure I sutures it was like I mean we had
Atari so and then and it wasn't that
interesting to me
right you know right that's true yeah so
it's like there's most of this stuff I'm
just completely either illiterate or an
incredibly incompetent what do you think
about game what do you think about this
new Pokemon go situation
I was just in the coffee shop with a man
that caught one in line it was like oh
look I just got a Pokemon smartphone and
I was trying to write a tweet about it
but it was too many characters and what
I was gonna say it was like if you had
told me 10 years ago that I would be in
a coffee shop while a guy caught a poke
and not his smartphone but I would have
told you I don't care about what guy
just caught a Pokemon I'm just like no
it's like I just found a good Groupon
what's the difference
the best Andy so what do you do for fun
it's not video games what do you what do
you do complain right furious yeah yeah
I write shitty tweet about why people
are having fun angrily yeah how dare
they no I well I have a family and so I
spend time with them talking to them
eating food
you know things like movies and museums
and stuff like that and if somebody asks
and I play golf you know about once
there were three weeks we're gonna then
we're gonna play they're not gonna play
we're gonna play a little Battlefront
cuz people want to see battle for which
is Star Wars oh alright it's great
I dunno what Star did you see the new
Star Wars movie yes what do ya know I
you know I I'm not as into it as
everybody but yeah like no that was fun
yeah
chitta great job oh I don't I don't you
know there again people get so into it
that you feel like you need a you need
to read a book before you see a movie
yeah or else you're like not getting the
optimal experience and I'm kind of like
I don't need to know much damn good
right exactly
somebody asks if you're forced to dress
up as a superhero what superhero would
it be good to cosplay any what would you
cosplay for comic-con do you have any or
would you go like would you go maybe
like a historical figure like Tesla like
you know what I'm saying like nerdy that
if it's are we talking about San Diego
then it would have to be like something
in a lemon
[Music]
that's [ __ ] crazy
that's ridiculous maybe like Hannibal
Lecter at the end when you have in ensue
no no I mean it would be hard because I
want some is there a superhero maybe I
would go as the dude from the people
about yeah just wear robes pajamas and
slippers
yeah like jelly shape if you roast it's
like you're sweating and you're walking
except I'd be Zeus and then cuz it's
like then you can wear it's a little
longer and you can you can throw things
at people like yeah there you go that's
Andy Andy abides somebody said yes
somebody asked it is a hot dog of
sandwich I say no it's its own food
terrible question that's not the
question by the way that you had Andy to
ask a question that he wasted it on that
I want you to remember that Deirdre
Duffy I know people are into that
conversation but I just can't care about
it Danielle library do we read these
comments yes oh this is actually a
question how do you deal with all the
fans because when you walk around you
get mobbed people well I have an innate
crabbiness no I actually I I kind of lay
low I mean like going back to our
earlier topic of me being old I'm not
like out partying I don't write it's
just you know and so like last night I
went to dinner with a friend that was in
town from you know working on a
comic-con thing and there we go I went
over to the Conan writers had a dinner
and then but like like 10:30 I'm like
yeah I should be in my room with my
pants off so I so I just kind of lay low
although it is kind of I do it is
irritating like in the CBS if people do
find you they think like that we're
still on the convention floor right
that's should not you know just a person
in need of hemorrhoid oh let's see will
you rather fight a hundred duck-sized
horses or one horse-sized duck one
hundred horse sized duck sized horn I
won a hundred yeah yeah duck side
upsides horse Oh like a lot of rice for
one giant cow the horses come out a
little odd but the horses do - really
I'll just kick you out
exactly yeah would you rather be sit or
Jedi would you rather be on the dark
side or the light side you said you were
crabby maybe you're a Sith I know no no
no I know I mean I would be a Jedi just
because the the Sith are just actually
it's one of the things I don't like
about Star Wars is that the bad guys are
too I mean aside from I wasn't loved as
a young person there's no like there's
no point of view to their evil that's
true there's no like there's no sort of
like all right I can see their point
where's like very and this is something
I just watched the x-men the last x-men
movie yes yes Sansa Stark in it yeah and
Magneto I'm always like you know what
I'm kind of on Magneto sorry yeah I'm
always sort of like you know what why
not they are [ __ ] super beings and
people are gonna be petty about it [ __ ]
you yeah it's motivated yeah yeah motive
like you understand where their animal
is coming from in Star Wars it's just
kind of like cut it for me I need a
little more persuading thank you go back
to work that's right and just remember
we don't care if a hotdog is a sandwich
or another thing it doesn't mean I don't
care and you look like if you're still
if you're looking for work and you've
given up keep trying
[Laughter]
all right thanks awesome he said you
look like a 45 year old eighth grader
I'm 49 I think they're talking to me
thank you Andy there we go now a king
dice miss I don't know how to add you to
this bro it doesn't say you're in the
thing no friends are in the game so
what's up
what's up were you at I did my best I
want you to know it does say no friends
are in the game we have no we had no
friends
no friends are they gay see right am i
doing something wrong
maybe you have to add them in a
different section I don't think so man I
don't think Oh friend requests yeah I
don't know I was trying to get people to
play but I guess that's not gonna happen
I think we go back to rocket League so
we can have people play what do you
think yeah sorry King I did try
I did try I tried my best rocket League
it is we're doing what the people want
whatever we're doing we're doing the
opposite of it oh wait he just wait that
person wait hold on
that person just added me so maybe now
they're in here it doesn't say it
doesn't say sorry man sorry bro all
right whatever we're going rocket League
sorry folks I tried yeah you got roasted
Setser epic forth andis never hit me
Andy and I have a great relationship
yeah Andy's uh yes Andy is a gentle
agenda he he's caressed me many times I
would say but now he has never he's
never done that all right let's uh go
back to I played for a minute perhaps
yeah I think it would be good and help
us out you can take this one what's the
wood all right well we're gonna create a
private match guys it's cocoa and cocoa
once again and we're gonna play in
utopia Coliseum I think let's hit this
boom I'm in you're in we're gonna create
that match yeah y'all get in there so
basically here's how you play it's very
easy it's very easy what happens is
we're gonna create this match
look we're in basically right trigger is
gas yeah
this moves you around okay you can like
jump with X okay
Oh like farts out a jet that's I need to
know god that's it
uh you be orange I'll be blue all right
I'll be blue you be orange you're who
are you alright y'all should we wait for
people to get in this I think people can
get in guys it's cocoa and cocoa this is
gonna be very embarrassing yeah if you
want to play it Beth now's your chance
y'all okay well can you put it at the
bottom in the middle please yeah
my older brother oh goodness Tori M's
brother gets a sweet shout-out I don't
know why people aren't in this match
yeah guys Beth is playing if you want to
play with Beth now's your chance
look what I've done for you special
opportunity strictly PlayStation oh no
this is gonna be terrible is anyone
gonna join Oh No just like really this
is like real life we had such a good
match going guys hey see it oh oh
goodness thank you you're welcome Tori
oh man no one's joining this do we go
back to battle we go back to battlefront
as well this is good cuz I can't even
stay on the track I don't think I guess
I'm it I guess maybe I should oh hey
what's up Oh mr. Keller oh my god well
that's right if you guys want to play
with Conan join our match out of the
chat hey everybody what's going on yeah
oh my god
oh maybe we should go back to benefit uh
what's happening we are playing we're
playing the run with you so you know
sorry
sorry very excited we're playing rocket
League but you've come in at the perfect
time or no one else is in the match so
we're just Beth and I playing against
each other so it's a little awkward
if you guys have questions to ask Conan
ask away tonight we've got Silicon
Valley yeah we're very excited a lot of
surprises actually tonight a lot of
surprise yes we have some surprises this
evening some people are gonna maybe stop
by it'd be really fun you got a tune in
I apologize for the gym shorts yeah I
have the knees of an 80 year old woman
who has apologized this is my actual
flesh tone so that's just something that
happens here I am that's right uh how do
you feel about Koenig I came back to
comic-con this year I was last year's
experience last year was phenomenal
that's why we're back and we're very
excited we have very excited I'm very
excited about tonight yes we have a
great open to the show
yes I hope you like it I'm not a work
went into it it cost us about four
million dollars to make and that's money
we don't have
so we hope you like it and we have
surprises throughout the week it's gonna
be fun that's right that's right a
favorite superhero did you get it at
work you could be a superhero other than
yourself you are very super heroic who
would you choose to be well let's see
that's really interesting
I like vision because yeah vision
because he's with Scarlet Witch am i
right yes and when I was a kid I thought
she was the hottest woman in the world
my brother collected comic books my
brother Luke I did not but he had a lot
of comic books on I used to read his
comic books and I thought she was so
sexy and and she's with visions just a
dud I don't understand why Carla witches
with vision depressing so anyway
somebody asked have you watched lost do
you like lost you're actually friends
with JJ lost what are we talking that's
it that's how you show
yes I watch so I also watch the show
Bonanza which ran from 1959 to 1974 lost
who's talking about lost anymore
do you like that yeah I like Hollywood
Squares to the original with Paul Lin so
why are you why are you talking about
shows from years ago have you played any
Pokemon go yet no I have not played
Pokemon go although I've been with you
and you've played Pokemon I've been
playing constantly yeah I've walked down
the street with this guy he'll go oh I
just got a squid blob and he gets all
excited and jumps around no I have not
played Pokemon go I just been focusing
on wearing shorts I guess thought that
was enough for me people asked have you
gotten out at all this processor walked
around yes you plan on doing that [ __ ]
yeah you're gonna see me around if you
see me come up if you're a woman feel
free to to hold me if you're a man feel
free to go further than that that's
really I'm on the gender scale I'm very
elastic
all right willing to try anything Sweden
says hi Sweden hello sweet shout-out to
Aspen in Aria Aspen in Aria western NRI
others due to massive been in Ras Sweden
Sweden you guys had the idea wasn't you
guys the thought of melting cheese
dipping bread into it wasn't that you I
don't know maybe I made that up but if
that was you my props to Sweden what a
great idea all right I think guys we
have to go so like why do we have to go
I just got here well that's it we're
done we're done streaming that's all we
have there so excitable is hi internet
vote do you like it I mean it why are
you not like it says hi hello and how
are you Scotland and Ireland and Ireland
listen Malaysia Berlin Berlin Philly
Philly Philly shout-out to Philly I love
Philly man you guys are tough that's
right
all right guys make sure to watch
tonight it's gonna be fun that's the
Silicon Valley plus a ton of great
surprise hashtag and you know props to
schedule I don't know Winchell's not a
thing he doesn't know what he's talking
I don't know what thank you coding thank
you thank you and thank you all for
joining us stop shouting
sorry I just subject just very excited
food we got a fallout not the vault boy
you